Are you still building a company with
open clue? This is so last week again.
It changed all the time. No, we have a
new app. It's called Pepper Clip and
it's going to help you build your zero
human company because it just it's just
better, right? So like until the next
one, but yeah, whatever. Uh so in this
live we are going to um build uh the
open sora because open AI kill sora but
I still want to create some funny AI
video. So we need an open-source
solution. That's what we are going to
build with paperclipip. And yeah, let's
go. Pepper clip opensource orchestration
from zero human zero immune companies.
Hire AI employees set goals, automate
jobs and your business run it runs
itself. Everything turns around one
mission when you set up that in the
onboarding. I'll show you after. But you
set up one main mission and then you
create a task which is basic it's not
even like a PR PL or just a GitHub
issues whatever it's just a task for the
AI to to do so. So then the task can be
what [__] whatever it can be but um it's
it's yeah it works as a business unit
more than a task or job to do to start
it. It's just oneliner and then it's
like thanks to AI it's just does
everything looks like that the dashboard
and see like so you're kind of like the
same UX UI done linear which is like
like a project management app uh it's
straightforward and that looks like open
CL you know like Alex fin diagram about
like yeah hired like 20 employees and
yeah they are mine now
>> is it the old Excel paper clip
>> so it's coming from uh video game called
Pepper Clip where you it's a point and
click and you have to click to create
paper clips. So, and then it's always
upgrading like your like the web page.
>> So, you and so then you autoclick and
then you can develop an AI.
>> Mhm. uh to
create more paper clips and at the end
of the game the AI is so advanced that
it terraform the planet earth to create
more paperclip so there is no more human
life and etc etc
>> only paper clips
>> exactly just to make paper clips because
the AI becomes sentient but still has
one mission clips so open AI shut down
Sora I want an app to create content
You want to see if you can get Disney
>> Yes, exactly.
>> to partner up with you.
>> Yeah, exactly. Like, yeah, Disney closed
the deal. I want to get it back.
>> And we will show you here how.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, so Pepper Clipper on board. Yes.
Boom. Uh, tech. And it really look like
it really look like a open close setup,
right? So that should be the first
screen when you run it for the first
time. I want open door.
I want I want to build the number one
number one AI uh content mobile app
uh which will replace
from open AI. That's the mission. That's
the goal. I want to make 1 million
uh band by Q2
because it's important to have
>> that would be so weird if it's okay.
>> Yeah, let's do that.
>> Uh okay, create your first agent. Uh CEO
because uh I'm CEO [__]
>> Mhm. Uh I can choose clo code or codex.
Uh I'm going to put clo code and I'm
going to take the big one opus. I'm just
>> What do you see when you press the more
agent adapter types?
>> Uh so Germany open code cursor pi open
getaway. So the co will be opus open. Uh
first task we are going to give the CEO
to do is to hire the first um uh
engineer which will be the CTO and
uh yes and that's it blah blah blah back
summary of everything to do great open
now we are on
the dashboard
>> okay cool is already working boom boom
boom uh I should see
an inbox alert once it's complete.
>> Oh yeah, because I confirm the fact that
we will create the engineer. So it's
just set up the setting up the agent
right now.
>> Uh routine uh we can explore that. So I
I I expect that to be just a crown job
that will repeat like
>> all the time. I can set up a new goal
for the um company or project. Tell the
CEO to contact Disney CEO and ask him to
test your app.
>> Okay.
>> So, okay. And I will create another
goal. Build
number one
AI.
I don't know exactly what is going to do
that, but uh enjoy.
>> Yeah, let's go.
>> Uh okay. Where was the CTO CO is going?
Uh, honestly I I like the interface.
It's pretty straightforward.
>> It looks really good.
>> Yeah. Define architecture. We are
building the mobile app storement
targeting. We back you to enjoy. Uh, if
you can do that, that would be helpful.
Um, primary model provide a pluggable
cling API runway pick. Okay.
I think I want to use replicate and file
AI. That would be easier.
Uh well ask it if it's easier and let's
see what it says.
>> Yep. Uh MVP plan down. Yes. So see okay.
So all of that it make like
architectural choices for us.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh ML cler back end. Oh no. Nope. I
don't like that. I don't like that.
MQ for the
for the Q system. That's good. Okay. So
leave a comment. I want to use the part
uh providers like replicate replicate
and
file AI instead of link
uh back end
uh next. Yes.
No. Next. Yes. Next. Yes.
uh tag superase uh DB [__] atlas I have
issues tag tag plane preview okay
and so this one is blocked but I just
commented no QA engineer database icon
close up piece okay
locker zero on board must approve I
think It's done right
inbox plan review if I want
recourse owner pay engineer CTO. Okay,
so that's done. No, do not fire the Q
engineer. I check the or already have
the Q engineer on staff. My comment was
about
Q at what?
Okay.
Uh clarify that note block PR engine
review and merge QA test after merge.
Okay. Uh
could uh implement industry
test
practices
that okay cool and now I want to see the
app. So
>> I'm going to ask uh build the MVP.
>> Yes. I want to see the MVP of the
website and the mobile app. And you do
it yourself
with the help
of your gym.
Let's [__] go.
Pretty sure buff. Okay. So, and why is
doing okay cost? Uh cost. It's free.
It's free.
>> Yeah, it's within your sub.
>> Yeah,
>> you How many million tokens did you use?
>> Um
>> it says it on the overview
usage 3.9 million.
>> Wait, already?
>> Yeah, already. I'm correct, right?
>> Uh token across request cop event. I
guess so.
Uh, that's a lot now.
>> Yeah. Well, if that wasn't if you did it
on Opus, that would be like $20 already.
>> Yeah, true.
>> Just for the plan.
>> Co subscription 1 million.
Okay. Uh, by project mobile. Okay. That
that's pretty cool. I I mean you can
have that in your company with like real
guys and see how much they consume like
you know um
>> yeah it's like they say at the bigger
companies right if you are a senior deaf
you have to consume at least so many
million tokens otherwise you're not
performing. Exactly. 100%. Oh. Uh, look.
Ah.
Uh. Wow. Wow. Wow. Everyone's walking.
Look.
How long have you guys been using Pepper
Clip for? Uh, I
this week I just tried this week. We are
exploring it as we go during the live
stream.
>> Becoming a professional when using.
>> Exactly. This has so much nicer UI for
agent creation than open 100%. Like I
and I like the the UX UI. The onboarding
is clear as [__] Like it's awesome.
>> Yeah, it's so easy to do.
>> Should we stop here because we let we're
going to have
>> Maybe when we post video we can show
some screenshots of the eventually
design and everything that was created.
>> We can even continue next week.
>> Oh, that's even better. Maybe Disney is
in by then.
>> Yes. Yeah. Like and I can push it live
on Versel. Yeah. I'm gonna prompt it,
push it to production next week and we
can have like a a series or something.
That would be cool. Mitchell, do you
want to do the conclusion based on based
on your like first impression of Pepper
Clip?
>> Oh, I was first thinking, yeah, we have
another one, but it actually looks good.
You have a great controller. Uh even the
design that they added, it just works.
So, I'm really looking forward to start
testing it
>> and build some of my own apps.
>> Nice. That's That's awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's see what we can do.
>> Let's see what we can do. And let's see
if we can close like 1 million in
revenue. We have to
>> Let's see what it does. I'm not going to
put in make me a million dollars. I
think I'm going to put in check how they
have a how the strategy of this company
works and rebuild it for me and see if I
can do it as well. Just copy the
strategy of a successful one.
>> Yeah.
Okay. Well, so let us know how it goes.
>> We'll do.
>> Thanks everyone. Thank you so much. Uh
subscribe because you are probably not
subscribers. There is only 500 100 not
even subscribers.
>> We need three more. But anyway, guys,
subscribe to the channel. Uh, thank you
for being in the chat. Mitchell, thank
you for your time and
>> byebye.